big fan of all Bollywood films a lot of
them like you know any country that
produces a thousand films a year as we
do is going to produce a lot which are
just light and entertainment and trivial
but Bollywood also produces it has the
whole alternate cinema phenomenon where
they produce some excellent firms the
importance of Bollywood in the Indian
case is and and perhaps in for other
cultures as well is that it is such a
popular medium it really by the themes
that it takes up it is able to influence
the culture as well apart from
reflecting it and in India certainly
Bollywood has been very progressive in
many ways for instance it has always
dealt with issues of religion by way of
promoting secularism by way of promoting
religious accommodation and respect for
for diversity these are positive things
on the other hand by also having had
films which were very traditional in
their portrayal of women for example I
as a woman would not see that as
positive I would think that you want to
see more space for women in cinema as
autonomous as agents of their own fate
so but but Bollywood now takes up a
great deal more and treats more
seriously it's a female characters I'm a
big fan of that